PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you learned
about some new tools
for computing certain limits.
In particular, you learned
about l'Hopital's rule.
So now you have the
ability to compute easily
some limits that before might
have been difficult to do.
So I have here four examples
of limits, some of which--
or maybe all of
which, or maybe none
of which or, well definitely
some of which-- will be,
you could use
l'Hopital's rule on.
So here they are.
Why do you pause the video and
take a few minutes to work them
all out, come back, and we
can work them out together.
Welcome back.
So we have these
four limits here.
And let's start
solving them, shall we?
So I'll just go from the first
one, and then I'll, you know,
go through them in order.
So limit (a) is the limit as x
goes to 1 of x to the a minus 1
over x to the b minus 1.
If we want to use
l'Hopital's rule,
we have to first
check that this is
a limit of an appropriate
kind of expression.
So that's, in particular,
a limit that is a 0 over 0
or infinity over infinity form,
so an indeterminate quotient.
And as x goes to 1, we see
that x to the a goes to 1.
So x to the a minus 1 goes to 0.
And similarly x to the b goes
to 1, so x to the b minus 1
goes to 0.
So indeed, this is a 0 over
0 indeterminate form, so we
can apply l'Hopital's rule.
So we apply l'Hopital's rule.
And it says that the limit as x
goes to 1 of x to the a minus 1
over x to the b minus 1.
OK, so what do we do?
What l'Hopital's
rule says is we can
take the derivative of
the top and the derivative
of the bottom, and then
the limit of the left side
will be equal to the
limit of the result
provided the result actually
has an existing limit, either
a real number or infinity
or minus infinity.
So in this case, this
says that this expression
is equal to the limit-- so
it's the same limit-- as x goes
1 of-- OK, so the
derivative of the top
is a x to the a minus 1, and
the derivative of the bottom
is b x to the b minus 1.
So l'Hopital's rule says
that these two limits
are equal provided that
the second limit exists.
So what is the second limit?
Well, we-- OK, we can do
some simplifications here.
Here there wasn't,
you know, a lot
of obvious simplifying
to be done.
But here there's an obvious
simplification step.
So this is equal to the limit
as x goes to 1-- so a over b
is just a constant, and
now the powers of x, this
is x to the a minus b.
But as x goes to 1,
x to the a minus b
goes to 1 no matter
what a and b are.
So at this point, this isn't
an indeterminate form anymore.
This is nice simple limit
we can just plug in.
So this is just
equal to a over b.
OK so that's part a,
straightforward application
of l'Hopital's rule.
Let's go look it part b.
So part b asks us
for the limit as x
goes to 0 of sine 5x over x.
So I'll put that
right here, maybe
I'll draw a little border.
So the limit as x goes to 0
of sine of 5x divided by x.
So again there's a question
of, you know, is this limit,
do we know what it is already?
And the answer is, maybe we do
and maybe we don't, but suppose
we don't.
So in that case, can we
apply l'Hopital's rule?
Well we check, and as x
goes to 0, sine of 5x.
So as x goes to 0, 5x goes to
0, so sine of 5x goes to 0,
and x goes to 0.
So this is another
0 over 0 form.
So we can apply
l'Hopital's rule.
So l'Hopital's rule says that
this is equal to the limit
as x goes to 0 of-- we take
the derivative of the top
and divide by the
derivative of the bottom.
So the derivative of the
top is just 5 cosine 5x.
And the derivative
of the bottom is 1.
So l'Hopital's rule
says the limit here
is equal to the limit here
provided this limit exists.
And now as x goes to 0,
well, OK, 5, 1 is constant.
So we're just looking at
the limit of cosine 5x here.
As x goes to 0, that just
approaches 5 times cosine of 0,
which is 1.
So this is equal to-- sorry,
the cosine of the 0 part is 1.
So it's 5 times 1, which is 5.
Now I should note that we
didn't actually really need
l'Hopital's rule for this one.
One thing you can remember is
that this limit is actually
the definition of the derivative
of sine of 5x at x equals 0.
So what we just did
with l'Hopital's rule
was use the derivative to
compute the derivative,
if you like.
So we used the fact that we
already knew the derivative
in order to compute it.
We could also just
say by definition,
this is the derivative
of sine 5x at 0,
which is 5 cosine of 0, which
is 1, which is 5, rather.
OK so that's part (b).
Now part (c) asks
for the limit as x
goes to 0 of x squared
minus 6x plus 2-- did
I do that right,
yes-- over x plus 1.
So this limit, you can't
apply l'Hopital's rule?
Why can't you apply
l'Hopital's rule?
Well, because it's not
an indeterminate form.
This limit is really
easy to compute.
You can just plug
in x equals 0 here.
The top is going to 2, and
the bottom is going to 1.
So the whole limit is going
to 2 divided by 1, which is 2.
So there's no-- not only, you
don't need l'Hopital's rule,
and also you can't
apply l'Hopital's rule.
This is not a form in which
l'Hopital's rule applies.
It's not an indeterminate
form, OK, so,
but OK, but the result
is very easy to compute.
So that's 2.
And we've got our
last one now which
is (d), the limit as x goes
to infinity of ln of 1 plus e
to the 3x quantity
divided by 2x plus 5.
OK, well is it obvious
what this limit is?
Not to me.
So OK, so then we can check.
It's a quotient.
So can we apply
l'Hopital's rule?
Well we can apply
l'Hopital's rule
if it's an
indeterminate quotient.
So what's happening
is x goes to infinity?
Well, let's do the bottom
first, because that's easy.
As x goes to infinity, 2x
plus 5 goes to infinity.
And, OK, as x goes to infinity,
e to the 3x goes to infinity.
So 1 plus e to the
3x goes to infinity.
So log of 1 plus 3 to
the 3x goes to infinity.
So this is an infinity
over infinity form.
That's an indeterminate form,
an indeterminate quotient.
So we can apply
l'Hopital's rule.
So l'Hopital's
rule says that this
is equal to the
limit of the quotient
of the ratio of the
derivatives, provided
that that limit exists.
So this is equal to the limit
as x goes to infinity of--
OK, so we need to look at
the ratio of the derivatives.
So the bottom one is easy.
That's 2.
For the top one, to
compute this derivative,
we need to use the
chain rule here.
So you take the derivative of
this, and you get, well, a log.
So on the bottom we
get 1 plus e to the 3x.
And then by the chain rule,
up top you get 3 e to the 3x.
Or, just rewriting this a
little bit in a nicer form,
this is the limit as
x goes to infinity
of 3 over 2 times e to the
3x over 1 plus e to the 3x.
All right, so now the question
is what do we do from here?
Well is this limit obvious?
Well, OK, so there are
two situations here.
One is, you might look at
this and you might already
know what this limit is.
The reason you might know that,
is that x goes to infinity,
e to the 3x is
going to infinity,
and 1 plus e to the 3x
is going to infinity.
So this is an infinity over
infinity indeterminate form.
And so you could apply
l'Hopital's rule to it again.
OK?
That's one thing you could do.
You might also look
at and say well,
these two things are
going to infinity
at exactly the same rate.
Right?
This plus 1 is almost
totally irrelevant.
Actually for purposes
of estimating
the magnitude of this fraction,
it is totally irrelevant.
When you take-- you
know, when 3x is big,
then e to the 3x is like
a billion or something.
So e to 3x is a billion.
So you have a billion
over a billion and 1.
So it's very, very close to 1.
It's going to get
closer and closer to 1.
So, OK, so if you didn't
trust that analysis
based on magnitudes,
I mean the idea here
is just that the most
significant term in the top
is the e to the 3x.
The most significant term on
the bottom is e to the 3x.
They dominate everything
else that appears,
which is just this little 1.
So that's going to
give you a ratio of 1.
If you don't trust
that analysis,
you can apply
l'Hopital's rule again,
and l'Hopital's rule will tell
you exactly the equivalent
thing.
When you take a
derivative, you'll
be left with 3 e to the 3x over
3 e to the 3x, which is just 1.
So in either case,
this part goes to 1.
So 3/2 times it
goes right to 3/2.
All right, so there you have it.
Four limits computed
with l'Hopital's rule.
Well one of them was computed
without l'Hopital's rule.
Remember, you always have
to check that you actually
have an indeterminate
form before you
apply l'Hopital's rule.
And that's all I have
to say about that.
So I'll end there.